if you've been paying particularly close
attention to our use of the factorial
operator and and in the videos on
permutations and combinations you may or
may not have noticed something that
might be interesting so let's just
review factorial a little bit so if I
were to say n n factorial that of course
is going to be n times n minus not side
times n minus 1 times n minus 2 and I
would just keep going down until I go 2
times 1 so I would keep decrementing n
until I get to 1 and then I would
multiply all of those things together so
for example and all of this is review if
I were to say 3 factorial that's going
to be 3 times 2 times 1 if I were to say
2 factorial that's going to be 2 times 1
1 factorial by that logic well that's
just I just keep decrementing until I
get to 1 but I don't have to decrement
here I'm already at 1 so I just
multiplied 1 now what about 0 factorial
this is interesting
0 0 factorial so one logical thing to
say well hey you know maybe 0 factorial
is 0 it's you know I'm just starting
with itself it's already below 1 and
maybe maybe it is 0 now what we will see
is that this is not the case that
mathematics some mathematicians have
decided and remember this is what's
interesting you know the factorial
operation this is something that humans
have have invented that they think is
just an interesting thing it's a useful
notation so they can define what it does
and math mathematicians have found it
far more useful to define 0 factorial as
something else to define 0 factorial as
and there's a little bit of a drumroll
here they believe 0 factorial should be
1 and I know based on the the the
reasoning the conceptual reasoning of
this this doesn't make any sense but
since we've already been exposed a
little bit to permutations I'll show you
why this is why this is a useful concept
especially in the world of permutations
and combinations which is frankly
we're factorial shows up the most if I
would say the most of the cases that
I've ever seen factorial and anything
has been in situations of permutations
and combinations and in a few other
things but mainly permutations and
combinations so let's review a little
bit we've said that hey you know if we
if we have n things and we want to
figure out the number of ways to permute
them into K spaces it's going to be it's
going to be n factorial over n minus
over n minus K factorial now we've also
said that if we had if we had n things
that we want to permute into n places
well this really should just be n
factorial the first place has you know
let's just do this so this is the first
place this is the second place this is
the third place all the way you get to
the nth place well there would be n
possibilities for who's in the first
position or which object is in the first
position and then for each of those
possibilities there would be n minus 1
possibilities for which object you
choose to put in the second position
because you've already put one into that
position now for each of these n times n
minus 1 possibilities where you've
placed two things there would be n minus
2 possibilities of what goes in the
third position and then you would just
go all the way down to 1 and this thing
right over here is exactly what we wrote
over here this is equal to this is equal
to n factorial but if we directly
applied this formula if we applied this
formula this would need to be n
factorial over n minus n factorial and
then you might see why this is
interesting because this is going to be
n factorial over zero factorial so in
order in order for this formula to apply
for even in the case where K is equal to
n even in the case where K is equal to n
which is this one right over here and
for that to be consistent with just
plain old logic zero factorial
needs to be equal to 1 and so the
mathematics community has decided hey
this thing we've constructed called
factorial
you know we said hey you put an
exclamation mark behind something in all
of our heads we say you kind of
countdown that number all the way to one
and you keep multiplying them four zero
we're just going to define this we're
just going to define make a mathematical
definition we're just going to say zero
factorial is equal to one and it's
actually quite useful